Yes. I'll pray for you. Any other
questions? The I have another one, but I
know a lot of people are waiting. So, if
let's see because that was quick. Yeah.
The other uh last week I called you
about miracles done by angels and it
blew my mind. I'm still trying to
meditate about it. You mean not
miracles? The power that angels have.
The powers. Yes. Yes. So, I'm I'm
wondering in John chapter 5, I know
there is a John 54. Yes, that is that
should be in the text and it's ancient
that an angel would come and stir up the
pool and anyone who got into the pool
would be here. Yeah. So, John Yeah. So I
agree that let's say this passage is
very important and my understanding is
like the angel there was like a Roman
pagan god who was healing through the
water but I might be wrong but my point
is like if even these angels were false
gods let's say my understanding at least
is that they're false they're demons if
they can heal how can we distinguish
true miracles from false miracles in
other words you don't base your faith on
miracles Jesus told you that yeah you're
right yeah in fact here let me give you
now let me repeat this question. If the
demonic realm, angelic creatures, evil
and good, have the power to do things
that we can't do like heal you or bring
diseases or cause tsunamis or tornadoes.
Then how do I know a miracle is from
God? And how do a miracle is not?
Because it's not the miracle, it's the
message that the miracle confirms. Of
course, but I'm going to give you from
the scripture this proof. I'm going to
give you from scripture. God already
told Israel in Deuteronomy 13:es 1 to10.
Deuteronomy 13:es 1-10 he says if a
prophet or a dreamer of dreams comes and
tells you about a sign that will take
place and it takes place it happens like
he said Deuteronomy 13:es
1-10 but then he tells you come let us
go after gods that neither you nor your
fathers knew do not listen to that
prophet or dream of dreams because the
Lord your God is testing you whether
you're going to obey his commands so
here God is telling you. They will do a
sign and wonder. It will happen. But
then he's going to tell you, "Okay, now
that I did the sign, follow me to
worship other gods." No. God is testing
you. Are you going to be deceived by the
miracle? Are you going to remain
faithful to the commandments and the
covenant that God has already
established before your eyes? That's
also saying, but I still I'm struggling
a bit because I think in the same
chapter, in the same book of John, they
also say, "Who has ever heard of anyone
healing the blinds?" Right? So, it seems
to me like Who has healed the blind
prior to the coming of Jesus? No,
exactly. No one. So my point is like it
seems to me there are some miracles that
only God can do. No, no, not at all.
Okay. It means among all the human
beings that showed up on earth, Jesus is
the only human being that did the
healing of the blind. Where did you get
that no angelic creature has healed the
blind? It's talking about Jesus the man.
They're looking at a man and among all
the prophets that came before him, they
haven't seen any man prior to him or
haven't heard any man prior to him
healing the blind. But who told you that
demons can't cause you to be blind and
heal you? Where'd you get that from?
That's awesome, Sam. Yeah, that
clarifies. Yes. And by the way, now that
Jesus came and did these miracles, he
now says that the disciples would do the
same miracles that he did. In fact, open
up Matthew 10. So, it wasn't only Jesus
who did miracles. When he did the
miracle of healing, opening blind eyes,
he then gave the disciples that power,
right? Matthew 10:es 1 to8.
Right. Do I need to read it though? No,
I mean, if you want me to read it for
you, right, go ahead. Make it Jesus
called his 12 disciples to him and gave
them authority to drive out impure
spirits and to heal every disease and w
sickness. These are the names of the 12
apostle. First, Simon who is called
Peter and his brother Andrew. James son
of Zebedee and his brother John. Philip
and Bartel Bartholomeu, Thomas and
Matthew the tax collector, James son of
Alfus and Tadas. Simon the Zealot and
Judah Judas the Scariot will betray
them. These 12 Jesus sent out with the
following instructions. Do not go among
the Gentiles or enter any town of the
Samaritans. Go rather to the lost sheep
of Israel. As you go, proclaim this
message. The kingdom of heaven has come
near. Heal the sick, raise the dead,
cleanse those who have leprosy, drive
out demons. Freely you have received,
freely give. So they're doing the
miracles of Jesus. Right. Yes. The
exactly same miracle. Yeah. Okay. Freely
you receive, freely you shall give.
Right. Yeah. And then what does he say
in John 14:12? says, "Truly I say to
you, he who believes in me shall do the
same works I have been doing, but a
greater number of these for as I I go to
the father." Right. Yes. Exactly. Yeah.
Raising the dead. Now, because when
Jesus comes now, he gives you the
authority and the power to do the
miracles he's been doing. So, no, it's
not that demons can't do the miracle of,
you know, healing the blind because they
can strike you with blindness like
locom. You go blind and heal you of it
through to deceive you. that what
they're talking about is up until this
time we have no record in Old Testament
history of anyone prior to this giving
sight to the blind.
Okay, it makes uh much much clearer.
Thank you very much, Sam. Yeah. Okay, so
is that clear now? Yeah, it's awesome
because I struggle a little bit with all
these text and you clarified it. So,
thank you very much. So, you excellent
questions, brother. I'm very proud of
you because that means you're studying
deeply. Pray I can walk worthy of the
Lord and be a doer of his word. All
right, brother. I pray for you and your
daughters. Thank you again. Take care.
Bye-bye.